je propose que nous commencions
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur nous reprenons ce
matin les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française on nous dit non
madame marie-sol Touraine en sa qualité
d'ancienne ministre de la Santé je vous
remercie beaucoup madame la ministre de
vous êtes mobilisés vous avez donc
exercé les fonctions de ministre de la
santé pendant toute la durée du
quinquennat de François Hollande de 2012
à mai 2017 or c'est précisément au cours
de ces cinq années que l'on peut situer
un premier point d'infection concernant
le nombre de signalements de tension
d'approvisionnement et de rupture de
stock de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur enregistré par la
NSM ce nombre fut multiplié par 10 entre
2008 et 2014 pour atteindre un point
haut à 438 signalements alors le chiffre
paraît très exact en réalité bon ça
dépendait à quelques jours près en 2014
contre 44 en 2008 pour le coup
l'augmentation est manifeste suivi en
2017 d'un nouveau record avec 530
déclarations à la NSM
qui avait conduit le Sénat d'ailleurs à
s'intéresser à ce problème en créant en
juin 2018 une mission d'information sur
les pénuries de médicalement auxquelles
nous participions madame la rapporteur
et moi-même vous aviez par exemple été
confronté dès l'été 2013 d'importantes
tension d'approvisionnement concernant
le Lévothyrox médicament indispensable
dans le traitement de diverses
pathologies thyroïdiennes
l'Académie nationale de pharmacie
évoquait en 2017 le démarrage d'un
décrochage inquiétant et en effet la
situation n'a fait depuis que s'aggraver
600 à 700 médicaments faisaient l'objet
d'une pénurie à l'été 2018 au moment
nous aviez nous avions réalisé cette
mission et actuellement ce sont quelques
2500 voire 3000 en fonction des semaines
et des suivants les critères qui sont
concernés il est vrai je le précise que
c'est le décret du 28 septembre 2012
pris par vous-même madame la ministre
qui a défini dans le droit français la
notion de rupture d'approvisionnement et
de toute sa portée à l'obligation pour
l'exploitant de médicaments lorsqu'il
anticipe une situation de rupture
potentielle d'approvisionnement d'en
informer la NSM la France faisait alors
figure de pionnière en Europe vous n'en
étiez d'ailleurs pas rester là et la loi
de modernisation de notre système de
santé du 26 janvier 2016 complété par le
décret du 20 juillet 2016 a marqué une
étape importante dans l'histoire
législative de la lutte contre les
pénuries de médicaments en insérant dans
le code de la santé publique une
définition une définition des fameux
mitaines médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et en imposant aux
exploitants la mise en oeuvre de mesure
de prévention spécifique les PGP ou
plans de gestion des pénuries vous nous
direz malgré tout si au regard des
graves difficultés actuelles et du un
caractère désormais chronique voire
systémique je pense que le voir est
presque de trop des tensions
d'approvisionnement ont pu
rétrospectivement jugé que ces mesures
étaient insuffisantes ou en tout cas
ont été mises en oeuvre de façon
insuffisante la catégorie de mitml MITM
est-elle en définitive une cote mal
taillée avec le recul les PGP n'ont-ils
pas montré leur inefficacité ou alors du
moins l'absence de suivi
véritablement rigoureux par ailleurs
aucune des mesures législatives et
réglementaire prise alors n'avait
vocation à agir directement sur les
origines des ruptures lorsque celle-ci
interviennent en amont de la
distribution du médicament au stade de
la fabrication qui est le grand sujet et
finalement émergent depuis ces dernières
années bref vous nous direz si à
l'époque vous aviez pris toute la mesure
du problème et si a posteriori il vous
semble qu'il aurait été possible
d'anticiper la gravité de la situation
actuelle ou si tous les sets à penser
que les mesures de prévention et de
gestion que vous aviez prise suffirait à
enrayer ou à ralentir le phénomène votre
expérience sera précieuse pour éclairer
notre commission d'autant que depuis
2017 vous n'avez pas vraiment quitté le
monde du médicament puisque vous
présidez en effet depuis juin 2019
l'organisation internationale d'achat de
médicaments United rattaché à
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé qui
vise à faciliter l'accès au traitement
dans les pays à bas revenu en réduisant
notamment le prix des médicaments vous
pourrez notamment nous parler à la
lumière de cette expérience des efforts
que vous aviez fournis en 2014 en tant
que ministre de la Santé pour renégocier
le prix absolument exorbitant et à
l'époque c'est-à-dire le la notion
d'exorbitant a appris toute sa dimension
ces dernières années du sauvalier
médicament contre l'hépatite C du
laboratoire
dont la mise sur le marché est souvent
considérée comme un tournant en France
du point de vue de l'accès des passions
au traitement présenté comme innovants
et de la gestion administrée du bruit du
prix des produits de santé sur toutes
ces questions madame la ministre je vais
immédiatement vous aider à la parole
pour un propos introductif et puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporterait de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434-13 434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal je vous invite
madame la ministre a prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant
que je le jure
je vous remercie madame la ministre vous
avez la parole merci madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs
je suis heureuse d'avoir l'opportunité
de
m'exprimer dans le cadre de votre
commission d'enquête et de rappeler les
difficultés auxquelles j'ai pu être
confrontées la manière dont j'y ai
répondu qui a représenté je crois et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez indiqué une étape
absolument décisive dans l'histoire de
notre politique en matière de lutte
contre les pénuries de médicaments c'est
en temps cancienne ministre des Affaires
sociales et de la santé que vous
modifiez fonction que j'ai exercé du 17
mai 2012 au 18 mai 2017 en effet sans
discontinuer et c'est dans ce cadre que
je me situerai puisque demi depuis 2017
je n'ai exercé aucune fonction
institutionnelle en France en relation
avec l'industrie du médicament ou me
permettant d'avoir des informations
particulières sur les sujets que vous
traitez comme vous l'avez indiqué depuis
le 19 juin 2019 je suis la présidente du
conseil d'administration d'unitaire qui
comporte par ailleurs un secrétariat
exécutif organisation multilatérale
partenaires de l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé basée à Genève qui au-delà
de la seule question des médicaments
facilite l'accès équitable à la santé
dans les pays à bas revenu ou à revenu
intermédiaire évidemment se préoccupe de
la négociation du prix des certains
produits de santé mais encore une fois
n'en reste pas là mais propos ne
s'arrêtent évidemment en aucune manière
engager cette organisation qu'il
s'agisse de son secrétariat exécutif ou
de son conseil d'administration alors
j'insisterai sur quatre points que je
voudrais préciser d'emblée en
introduction de cette audition entre
2012 et 2017
jamais eu à connaître d'un certain
nombre de pénuries de produits de santé
pénurie malgré tout limité puisque leur
nombre était environ 10 fois inférieures
à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui selon les
données publiques de l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament et des
produits de santé la NSM ce sont les
pénuries de vaccins qui ont été les plus
sensibles au cours de cette période et
j'indique que cette situation n'était
pas propre à la France ces situations et
ces ma deuxième observation liminaire
m'ont amené à intervenir à chaque fois
pour sécuriser la situation des patients
mais aussi pour concevoir un socle
législatif et réglementaire de
régulation qui jusque là était quasi
inexistant
ce nouveau socle législatif et
réglementaire s'est inscrit dans le
cadre plus général de la politique du
médicament que j'ai porté autour de
quatre piliers
et c'est ma troisième observation 4
piliers qui sont la transparence la
sécurité l'innovation et donc la
régulation cette politique du médicament
est plus largement la politique des
produits de santé que j'ai porté c'est
inscrite dans le cadre politique qui
faisait dans le cas d'une politique qui
faisait de l'accès de tous à la santé et
de l'amélioration de la santé de tous
une priorité qui a été déclinée d'abord
dans la stratégie nationale de santé de
2013 puis dans la loi de modernisation
de notre système de santé du 26 janvier
2016 avant cette période là il n'y avait
pas de stratégie nationale de santé dans
notre pays enfin il me paraît nécessaire
de distinguer et c'est probablement
l'une des difficultés du travail auquel
vous êtes confronté les réponses à
apporter à un phénomène dont les causes
sont multiples car les risques de
tension d'approvisionnement ou de
pénurie ne peuvent se ramener à un
mécanisme unique incidence sur la chaîne
de production taille réduite du marché
existant ou du marché potentiel tension
accrue par un niveau de consommation
trop élevé stratégie industrielle choix
des acteurs de la filière la diversité
des enjeux appelle sans doute une
diversité de réponses donc je voudrais
revenir sur ces différents points tout
d'abord
de 2012 à 2017 j'ai en effet été
confronté à un certain nombre de
pénuries de produits de santé qui montre
enfin qui d'après les données donc de la
NSM montre qu'elle se situe est alors à
un niveau relativement faible et stable
puisque de 2012 à 2017 c'est entre 300
et 400 déclarations de rupture qui ont
été déclarés chaque année 345 en 2014
356 en 2016 je reprends pas les chiffres
ce nombre a été multiplié par quasiment
10 entre 2016 et 2022 et bien que à
l'époque le phénomène des pénuries ne
s'impose pas comme un phénomène
d'opinion publique extrêmement pragnant
il s'est imposé à moi comme un sujet
d'attention compte tenu de son impact
potentiellement important pour les
patients déstabilisant pour les patients
et pour les différents professionnels
qu'il s'agisse des ou des médecins les
questions relatives aux produits de
santé sont toujours des questions
sensibles néanmoins je veux insister sur
le fait qu'entre 2012 et 2017 le sujet
des pénuries n'a pas été l'un des sujets
les plus difficiles ou les plus
prévenants permanents auxquels j'ai été
confronté en dehors de la question
particulière des vaccins en effet parmi
les ruptures d'approvisionnement dont
j'ai eu à connaître les plus
préoccupantes ont concerné des vaccins
il convient d'insister sur le fait que
ces pénuries étaient pour la plupart
mondiales une situation particulière
néanmoins concernait les vaccins
trivalents DTP diphtérie tétanos polio
qui était alors les seuls vaccins
obligatoires on ne trouvait sur le
marché depuis 2008 que des vaccins
exavalents comprenant outre le DTP 3
vaccins recommandés mais non
obligatoires il ne s'agissait donc pas
de pénurie au sens strict puisque que la
difficulté n'était pas que l'on ne
pouvait pas trouver de vaccins pour se
faire vacciner mais que l'on ne pouvait
pas se faire vacciner avec les seuls
vaccins obligatoires ce qu'une partie de
l'opinion acceptait mal on a sans doute
oublié mais c'est ça a été une époque où
déjà des pétitions la pétition joyeuse
par exemple des pétitions circulaires
pour demander ou exprimer des doutes sur
les vaccins il se trouve que les mêmes
vaccins exavalents étaient les seuls
commercialisés dans d'autres pays
européens de la même manière sans
provoquer de tension sociale
particulière et cela n'incitait donc pas
les industriels à répondre à une demande
qui apparaissait à la fois spécifique et
limitée j'ai fait mettre en place un
dispositif à la demande pour que les
patients qui le souhaitaient puissent
accéder à aux seuls obligatoires mais
pour moi
l'enjeu majeur était moins celui de la
disponibilité des produits que celui de
la défiance vaccinale systémique qui
s'installait dans notre pays et dont il
faut bien dire qu'elle s'était accrue
après l'épisode de grippe à H1N1 de 2009
et se traduisait par exemple par une
extrême réticence face à la vaccination
contre la grippe et encore plus à la
vaccination HPV cela m'a conduit à
confier en mars 2015 une mission sur la
politique vaccinale à la députée
Sandrine Hurel posante explicitement la
question de l'acceptation sociale des
vaccins ce rapport a servi de base à la
mise en place d'une nouvelle stratégie
vaccinale qui s'est d'ailleurs
poursuivie après 2017 appuyez sur un
débat citoyen et une conférence de
consensus scientifique qui se sont
tenues en 2016 et dont le pilotage avait
été confié au professeur à l'afficheur
deuxième exemple au printemps 2016 le
laboratoire danois SSI équivalent de
l'Institut Pasteur
sous-traitant de Sanofi Pasteur MSD pour
le BCG a fait état de défauts de qualité
se traduisant par une moindre efficacité
du vaccin nous sommes sensuels dans un
institut du niveau de l'Institut Pasteur
donc nous sommes loin de en tout cas
géographiquement de la Chine ou de
l'Inde les autorités danoise ont alors
en raison des défauts de qualité retenu
des lots qui devaient être livrées à la
France cela portait sur 200 000 vaccins
200.000 flacons ce qui a obligé à
rechercher des alternatives avec le
vaccin polonais biomède Lublin au delà
des démarches engagées pour trouver des
lots de vaccins le Haut Conseil pour la
santé publique a été saisi pour définir
des critères de priorisation des enfants
à vacciner en fonction de leur risque
d'exposition dans ce cas il y a eu un
défaut dans le processus de fabrication
alors que depuis le 1er janvier 2006 le
vaccin danois était le seul disponible
compte tenu de l'arrêt de la
commercialisation des autres vaccins BCG
qui alimentaient le marché français
jusque là j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que la vaccination BCG n'était
plus obligatoire pour l'ensemble de la
population depuis 2007
fin 2016 la NSM a été informée c'est un
troisième exemple que les allocations de
vaccins contre l'hépatite A et
l'hépatite B pour le marché français ne
permettrait de couvrir qu'une petite
partie des besoins des adultes dans
notre pays en 2017 13% seulement des
besoins compte tenues de difficultés
rencontrées par le principal fournisseur
le laboratoire GSK la capacité de
production du vaccin contre l'hépatite A
de GSK rester limitée du fait de
l'inondation de son site de production
en 2015 et d'autres difficultés de
production sont apparues en 2016 pour
les vaccins contre l'hépatite B les
ruptures ne concernaient que les vaccins
adultes mais étaient très préoccupante
au regard d'abord de l'obligation
vaccinale contre l'hépatite B faisant
sur les professionnels de santé et les
professionnels médico-sociaux ainsi que
sur tous les étudiants admis en deuxième
année d'étude de santé
ainsi que sur plusieurs professions par
exemple les personnels travaillant dans
les 10 enfin les pompiers les pompes
funèbres travaillant thanatocratie etc
il y avait par ailleurs la nécessité de
vacciner les personnels engagés dans les
opérations extérieures sur certains
terrains d'intervention il y avait donc
des alternatives ont été recherchées des
recommandations de schéma vaccino
alternatif ont été élaborés par les
sociétés savantes je dois dire qu'un
doute a existé quand au respect par le
laboratoire de ses obligations légales
de mise sur le marché français de ces
vaccins un plan d'action pour la
rénovation de la politique vaccinale a
été organisée autour de quatre axes une
meilleure information une meilleure je
passe vite là dessus une meilleure
gouvernance un meilleur
approvisionnement et une concertation
citoyenne le meilleur approvisionnement
comportait un certain nombre de mesures
relatives à la lutte contre les pénuries
portant notamment sur la constitution
préventive de stock et la simplification
des autorisations d'importations en
urgence puisque c'est une difficulté à
laquelle nous avions été confrontés pour
le BCG en dehors des vaccins d'autres
médicaments ont subi des tensions vous
avez évoqué la lévothyroxine je pourrais
évoquer d'autres molécules à chaque fois
des alternatives ont pu être proposées
avec le soutien des sociétés savantes et
le Haut Conseil pour la santé publique
c'est une situation qui n'est cependant
jamais satisfaisante puisqu'elle
provoque le stress des patients
l'incertitude des professionnels
et des risques de iyatrogénie
médicamenteuse même s'il y a des travaux
qui sont portés là de ce qui portent sur
cette question j'ai donc misé ma le
deuxième point que je souhaite aborder
j'ai donc mis en place un socle de
régulation
législative et réglementaire qui jusque
là était limité avant 2012 la
réglementation prévoyait des obligations
générales d'informations des autorités
sanitaires par exemple
lorsqu'un produit était retiré du marché
mais ne traitait pas spécifiquement de
la question des tensions ou des ruptures
d'approvisionnement ni des réponses à
mettre en place en 2012 un décret que
vous avez cité madame la Présidente a
mis en place un dispositif de prévention
et de remonter de l'information ce
décret du 28 septembre 2012 est venu
renforcer les obligations qui pesaient
sur les différents acteurs de la chaîne
pharmaceutique notamment les obligations
de services publics des grossistes
répartiteurs afin d'optimiser les
approvisionnements du marché français
des centres d'appels d'urgence
permanents ont été mis en place par les
exploitants pour le signalement des
ruptures par les pharmaciens d'officine
cette première étape paraît aujourd'hui
à de soi il faut se rappeler que ces
dispositifs de veille et d'information
n'existaient pas un comité de suivi et
j'insiste sur ce point parce que c'est
peut-être une piste pour la suite un
comité de suivi de l'application du
décret donc l'objet était défini et
relativement circonscrit a été mise en
place au ministère au sein de la
Direction générale de la santé qui
réunissait l'ensemble des
administrations concernées la NSM la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale la
DGCCRF la direction de la concurrence
regroupait également les représentants
des industries du médicament et les
acteurs de toute la chaîne du médicament
que ce soit les pharmacies d'officine ou
à usage intérieur les ordres
professionnels etc ainsi que bien sûr
les associations de patients
ce processus c'est poursuivi avec
l'article 151 de la loi de modernisation
de notre système de santé du 26 janvier
2016 pardon dont la préparation a débuté
dès après le lancement la stratégie
nationale de santé en 2013
article 151 la loi qui a introduit pour
la première fois dans le Code de Santé
Publique un dispositif de prévention et
de gestion des ruptures la catégorie des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur apparaît pour la première fois
elle est définie il s'agit du médicament
ou de la classe de médicaments pour
lesquels une interruption de traitement
est susceptible de mettre en jeu le
pronostic vital des patients à court ou
moyen terme ou représente une perte de
chance importante la notion de rupture
d'approvisionnement est elle-même
précisée
c'est l'incapacité pour une pharmacie
d'officine ou à usage intérieur de
dispenser un médicament dans un délai de
72 heures maximum donc ce qui nous
apparaissait commettre le maximum de ce
qui pouvait être
supporté acceptable je ne sais pas mais
supporter en tout cas par le système
cette notion est elle-même différenciée
selon qu'elle est liée à des problèmes
de fabrication ou de distribution de
nouvelles obligations ont été instaurées
à l'égard des entreprises
pharmaceutiques et des grossistes
répartiteurs les entreprises vous l'avez
indiqué doivent désormais définir des
plantes prévention des pénuries
constituer des stocks de matières
premières ou de produits finis définir
des sites alternatifs de production
identifier des alternatives
thérapeutiques les grossistes
répartiteurs ne peuvent exporter des
médicaments que s'ils ont rempli leurs
obligations de services publics et qu'il
ne s'agit ni de médicaments en intérêt
thérapeutique majeur
ni de produits en risque de rupture
c'est un point important puisque parfois
il peut y avoir la tentation d'attribuer
à d'autres marchés que le marché
français des produits qui lui sont
destinés
enfin les modalités de dispensation au
détail des médicaments en rupture ou
risque de rupture peut être adaptée et
les pharmacies à usage intérieur peuvent
désormais délivrer au public et au
détail des médicaments concernés ce
dispositif a été précisé par un décret
du 20 juillet 2016 et par des arrêtés
des 26 et 27 juillet 2016 qui ont fixé
la liste d'une part des vaccins devant
faire l'objet de plantes gestion de
pénurie et d'autre part des classes
thérapeutiques
contenant des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeurs à cette date je
n'ai pas regardé l'évolution des arrêtés
à cette date il y avait 25 vaccins sur
le premier arrêté et environ 250
catégories de traitement
les gouvernements suivants me
semble-t-il ont prolongé ces plans en
poursuivant en négociant notamment avec
Bruxelles les conditions dans lesquelles
les entreprises devaient constituer leur
stock les autorités européennes étaient
initialement assez réticentes à l'idée
de la mise en place des stocks et je me
réjouis de voir que elles ont évolué sur
ce point-là cette politique de
régulation s'inscrit dans le cas d'une
politique plus globale et je ne crois
pas que l'on puisse mettre de côté les
autres aspects de la politique du
médicament car les pénuries viennent
s'inscrire dans un cadre plus général le
premier volet de la politique du
médicament que j'ai porté et celui de la
transparence à la suite du scandale du
Médiator Xavier Bertrand a fait voter
une loi le 29 décembre 2011 relative au
renforcement de la sécurité sanitaire
qui a posé le principe des liens
d'intérêt général il m'est revenu de
donner a contenu concret à cet
engagement ce qui n'a pas été sans
difficulté avec le décret du 21 mai 2013
dit sanchine Act qui a permis notamment
la mise en place de la première base de
données publiques recensant les liens
d'intérêt entre les entreprises et les
professionnels de santé ce site
transparence santé a permis aux
professionnels et aux associations de
déclarer leurs liens avec les
entreprises de production ou de
commercialisation des produits de santé
ainsi que les rémunérations qu'ils sont
susceptibles d'en recevoir je tiens à
insister que sur le fait que lien
d'intérêt ne veut pas dire
nécessairement conflit d'intérêt c'est
un point qui va de soi sans doute ici
mais qui ne va pas toujours de soi
la transparence est aussi mais j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir plus tard la
transparence sur les prix et c'est un
point évidemment important le deuxième
volet de la sécurité que j'ai porté
c'est celui de la sécurité sous toutes
ses formes
la sécurité sanitaire c'est évidemment
garantir aux patients qu'ils pourront
avoir au traitement dont ils ont besoin
cela renvoie donc au risque de pénurie
la sécurité c'est la qualité des
produits et l'indemnisation juste et
rapide des victimes d'accidents céréales
le dispositif mis en place et géré par
l'Office national d'indemnisation des
accidents médicaux l'ONIAM s'est
installé dans notre paysage la sécurité
c'est aussi le bon usage des médicaments
en 2013 on évaluait à 48 le nombre de
boîtes de médicaments que chaque
Français détenait dans son armoire à
pharmacie parmi ces médicaments les
antibiotiques figurent en bonne place
depuis longtemps sans que l'on puisse
identifier de raison pour laquelle les
Français consomment à ce point plus
d'antibiotiques que leurs voisins
puisque la France est le quatrième pays
plus gros consommateur d'Europe
d'antibiotiques après la Grèce la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie
c'est un enjeu de sécurité car c'est
bien connu l'usager excessif
d'antibiotique des bouches sur un risque
d'antibio-résistance en 2015 l'Institut
de Weiss sanitaire qui depuis a été
absorbée par santé publique France avec
évalué à 160 000 le nombre de patients
contractant une infection par un germe
multirésistant et à 13000 le nombre de
ceux qui en mouraient ce phénomène est
évidemment pas seulement français il a
été érigé en priorité par l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé en mai 2015 j'ai
pris des mesures pour lutter contre ce
phénomène dès 2014 avec notamment le
lancement de l'expérimentation de la
dispensation des antibiotiques à l'unité
et l'élargissement des compétences de la
Haute Autorité de Santé désormais en
charge de l'élaboration d'un guide
thérapeutique la sécurité c'est enfin la
sécurité sanitaire de façon plus globale
j'ai déjà eu à répondre avez des
questions de vos collègues ou certains
qui sont présents sur ce terrain je n'y
reviens pas je suis prête à répondre à
vos questions bien sûr je me contenterai
d'indiquer que contrairement à ce que
semble l'affirmer l'une de mes
prédécesseurs le transfert de les Prusse
au sein de santé publique France n'a
rien impacté la qualité du suivi des
stocks le troisième pilier je vais vite
sur celui là parce que j'aimerais qu'on
ait un peu de temps d'accord pour
laisser la place aux questions de Madame
la rapporteur et ça vous donnera
l'occasion de toute façon de rebondir le
troisième pilier est celui de
l'innovation qui renvoie à toute une
série de choix le débat actuel sur la
relocalisation trouve un écho dans celui
plus ancien du choix entre industrie
d'innovation ou industrie de
blockbusters la production française
reste centrée sur des produits à faible
valeur ajoutée en raison du choix des
industriels et c'est récemment que l'on
assiste
un transfert vers des médicaments plus
innovants de niche qui s'accompagnent de
l'abandon de production plus anciennes
ce qui est une difficulté je veux
insister sur le fait que la France est
le premier pays à avoir mis en place un
dispositif d'accès à des traitements ou
dispositifs innovants avant même leur
mise sur le marché avec ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque l'autorisation
temporaire d'utilisation qui est devenue
accès compassionnel ou avec un forfait
innovation pour les traitements médicaux
forfait pour les traitements non
médicamenteux pardon plusieurs produits
en ont bénéficié dont le nouveau
traitement pour l'hépatite C ou la
vasteindre pour la démêla par exemple
enfin ma dernière observation donc je
vais très vite sur l'innovation
quelles sont les initiatives ou les
pistes dans lesquelles sur lesquels on
pourrait aller contenu de
ce que il s'agit d'un phénomène multi
factorielle
d'abord il y a et c'est ce à quoi j'ai
été pour l'essentiel confronté des
problèmes sur la il peut y avoir des
problèmes sur la chaîne de production
industrielle
or pour les vaccins par exemple
on sait que c'est un produit peut
résilient c'est-à-dire que il faut deux
ans pour relancer une chaîne de
production pour un vaccin pour un
médicament classique c'est environ 6
mois un an pour un médicament injectable
deux ans pour un vaccin et donc la clé
est sans doute d'éviter de se retrouver
dans une situation de dépendance à
l'égard d'une seule entreprise
ce qui relève de la politique
industrielle n'est pas simple mais
oblige à des négociations d'anticipation
l'augmentation de la demande mondiale à
sans doute est un facteur qui joue de
plus en plus en particulier pour les
Antilles enfectieux et j'arrive à ce qui
est parfois présenté comme un enjeu pour
les pénuries qui est la question du prix
il y a nécessairement une tension entre
les impératifs de bonne rémunération des
industriels de juste rémunération des
industriels et celui de garantie et de
l'accès de tous aux médicaments un
médicament qui serait si cher que
personne ou très peu pour être y accéder
n'est pas un dispositif
satisfaisant la difficulté tient moins
selon moi à la faible rémunération
supposée des médicaments anciens qu'à
l'évolution du modèle économique des
industriels qui sont en train de passer
d'un modèle fondé sur la vente massive
de médicaments à bas prix à un modèle de
niche favorisant des innovations de
rupture à des prix très élevés et les
industriels ont alors tendance à
sous-investir dans les chaînes de
production vieillissante ce qui favorise
des risques d'incident technique ou des
interruptions en raison de défaut de
qualité l'un des défis me semble-t-il et
que l'industrie du médicament français
n'abandonne pas la production des
médicaments anciens
indispensables au seul profit des niches
d'innovation et cela peut faire partie
des discussions et des négociations avec
les industriels il me paraît normal que
le prix de médicaments ancien baisse
jusqu'à un certain prix à un certain
point pour permettre de supporter
l'arrivée sur le marché de nouveaux
médicaments c'est le principe de la
régulation et je ne crois pas que la
comparaison internationale des prix nous
permettre d'aller très loin doit être
manié avec précaution car mon expérience
m'a enseigné que les prix ne sont pas
transparents il y a le prix affiché et
les rabais qui sont consentis de façon
non publique par les différentes les
différents organismes payeurs et c'est
en soi une difficulté j'observerai par
ailleurs que les pays où les prix sont
systématiquement plus élevés par exemple
les États-Unis
également confrontés à des pénuries et
je réinsiste sur le fait qu'un certain
nombre de pénuries auxquels nous pouvons
auquel j'ai été confrontés étaient des
pénuries tout à fait mondiales ce qui
rend la situation particulièrement
difficile madame la Présidente je
m'arrête là peut-être pourra-t-on
explorer des pistes de proposition de
façon plus plus précise dans notre
échange mais je ne veux pas
disons aller plus loin dans cette
intervention linéaire je vous remercie
madame la ministre déjà ce propos très
dense et très complet je passe tout de
suite la parole à Madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur
merci madame la ministre pour
effectivement une introduction très
dense je vais commencer par peut-être
poser
la question sur sur le prix du des prix
des médicaments vous l'avez dit les
pénuries les causes des pén sont multi
factorielles donc ça serait vraiment
trop simpliste de s'arrêter sur un des
éléments mais il est vrai que lors de
nos auditions cette question des prix
trop bas des médicaments matures a été
très récurrente on va dire et
effectivement vous l'avez dit d'un côté
c'est pris bas et de l'autre côté les
prix sur pour les médicaments innovants
très innovants qui s'envole et on a cité
le sovaldy mais il y aurait bien
d'autres exemples à donner moi je
voudrais vous demander communiste vous
avez accompagné la démarche de maîtrise
des dépenses de santé et chaque année
nous nous votons ou pas le PLFSS avec
une enveloppe
particulière enfin une enveloppe dédiée
je dirais au niveau du du médicament
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que au
niveau donc de ces Tanda cette en dame
sur les médicaments on est allé un peu
trop loin d'autant que en quelque sorte
on assiste à des vases communicants vous
l'avez dit dans vos propos c'est à dire
qu'on va on va tirer vers le bas les
médicaments matures au profit des
médicaments innovants donc là est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas un rééquilibre à un
juste rééquilibre à trouver parce
qu'effectivement le défi et le danger et
on l'a bien perçu au niveau de nos
auditions c'est cet abandon des
médicaments matures au profit des
médicaments innovants donc là est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'au niveau de
l'ONDAM il faut arrêter de faire en
sorte que cette médicament soit en
quelque sorte la variable d'ajustement
des maîtrises de la maîtrise de de la
santé c'est la première chose la
deuxième deuxième élément c'est
concernant la liste des médicaments
un intérêt thérapeutique majeur c'est
vraiment une liste qui revient beaucoup
tout le monde il va de sa liste si je
puis m'exprimer aussi au niveau européen
au niveau national et on sent bien on
voit bien que il serait indispensable
qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule et même liste
pour qu'il y ait une véritable
coordination de cette politique du
médicament au niveau au moins européen
la liste des MITM qui a été codifiée en
2016 et souvent considéré comme
difficile d'usage car beaucoup trop
extensive et vous savez que y compris le
gouvernement travaille actuellement à
une notion beaucoup plus
restreinte est-ce que au moment où vous
vous étiez ministre vous avez abordé un
tel travail de mise en place donc d'une
d'une liste plus réduite et est-ce que
les listes dont vous avez écho
aujourd'hui vous paraissent de nature à
pouvoir être
susceptibles d'aider à réduire les
pénuries de médicaments troisième
élément que je voudrais vous poser on a
déjà eu l'occasion d'avoir
des échanges sur sur cette sur cette
question
quand vous étiez ministre et donc moi en
tant que sénatrice mais je me dis que
vous allez peut-être y être beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus sensible maintenant
que vous avez vous êtes à la tête donc
du conseil d'administration d'une
organisation internationale unitaire
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que la
licence d'office
qui a utilisé d'ailleurs par certains
pays à bas à bas revenu pour pour
générer notamment des traitements qui
sont vendus ailleurs à des prix
exorbitants est-ce que vous ça ne vous
paraît pas être un dispositif qui puisse
être transposable en France sur certains
certains médicaments parce qu'on a vu
que notamment pendant la période du
covid il y a eu des moments où il aurait
peut-être été judicieux d'utiliser ce
dispositif
on nous a beaucoup dit de c'est une la
même question dans dans lors de nos de
nos auditions des différents acteurs et
actrices qu'il y avait en fait un défaut
de gouvernance et de pilotage d'ensemble
de la politique du médicament et
d'ailleurs là j'ai vu que récemment
notamment le LEM préconise la création
d'une énième nouvelle instance au
commissariat dédié à la lumière de votre
expérience ministérielle est-ce que
selon vous le pilotage de cette
politique des médicaments doit être
améliorée en effet et si oui dans quelle
direction et je ça vient en écho avec
une cinquième question puisque quand
vous avez été à la tête du ministère
vous avez cherché notamment à
restructurer notre système d'agence
sanitaire et d'ailleurs vous avez vous y
avez apporté une réponse à cette
éparpillement puisque en 2016 vous avez
été à l'initiative de la création de
santé publique France donc quel rôle
pourrait être celui de santé publique
France non plus en situation
exceptionnelle mais dans le cadre d'un
fonctionnement courant mais on le voit
bien qu'il est défaillant de la chaîne
du médicament
enfin est-ce que vous avez
ressenti en tant que ministre de la
santé que la puissance publique avait
les moyens et les outils pour préserver
l'accès aux soins en toute sécurité face
au choix des industriels je le dis de
manière beaucoup plus claire nous voyons
effectivement
des défaillances
au système tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
avec les industriels qui choisissent de
poursuivre telle ou telle fabrication
sans beaucoup de possibilités pour les
gouvernements de pouvoir peser d'une
façon ou d'une autre ou d'une façon
suffisante est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'il y aurait des pistes publics pour
faire en sorte que aux côtés du secteur
privé il puisse y avoir effectivement
fabrication et
distribution de médicaments
la roulettes publiques sur une liste
restreinte évidemment de médicaments un
peu en fait comme la GEPS pour elle
faire aujourd'hui elle a plus les moyens
de de produire de fabriquer elle a
recours à la sous-traitance mais ça peut
être un modèle qu'on pourrait qu'on
pourrait dupliquer par rapport à une
liste plus restreinte enfin et ça sera
ma deuxième
ma dernière ma dernière question
évidemment cette comment dirais-je cette
production de de médicaments donc qui
serait en fait un outil public ou privé
non lucratif ne veut pas se faire
seulement
en France il faut qu'il y ait une
réflexion aussi européenne et qu'il y
ait une harmonisation européenne là
encore on l'a vu dans dans nos
différentes auditions puisque nous
sommes nous sommes allés à Bruxelles et
puis
aussi au Pays-Bas nous avons nous avons
pu constater qu'il y a aussi une prise
de conscience au niveau européen de
cette difficulté d'ailleurs il y a eu
des mobilisations des politiques lors
des vaccins qui a été intéressante donc
là encore si à cette initiative en
France
il faut une harmonisation européenne
qu'en pensez-vous à la lumière de votre
expérience internationale je vous
remercie
madame le ministre je vous laisse
répondre à cette liste substantielle de
questions oui sur des questions mais qui
sont convergentes avec votre
intervention fondamentales sont des
questions essentielles et au-delà même
de la question des pénuries pour être
honnête puisque elle renvoie à la
manière dont on conçoit l'organisation
d'un système de santé les relations
entre les acteurs publics et les acteurs
privés dans un pays dans un continent
mais dans un pays où nous avons toujours
défendu
l'existence des acteurs privés c'est à
dire que le système français et c'est
d'ailleurs à la fois une source de
richesse et une source de richesse
intellectuelle politique etc pas
seulement de richesses financières et
une source de complexité c'est que
beaucoup d'acteurs privés sont à
l'origine de la production de produits
de santé ou de soins avec un mécanisme
de régulation publique et donc cela peut
provoquer un certain nombre de
difficultés et la première question que
vous posez sur
le point de savoir si nous ne sommes pas
allés trop loin en termes de
de pression ou de maîtrise des dépenses
de de médicaments
en tout cas je ne crois pas que ça a été
le cas entre 2012 et 2017
qui a été une période qui a été marquée
notamment par l'irruption de façon
consolidée dégénériques c'est à dire que
l'un des enjeux de la de cette période
ça a été de faire accepter l'idée que on
pouvait passer du médicament de marque
entre guillemets ou médicament générique
au bout d'un certain nombre d'années
donc ça pose la question des brevets et
je vais revenir sur ce point-là qui est
un point absolument essentiel mais donc
alors que j'insiste avant cette période
là les génériques existaient évidemment
les ministres de la Santé
faisaient la promotion des médicaments
génériques ça c'est aucun doute sur la
question mais les médicaments génériques
ne s'étaient pas imposées et il y avait
souv vous des débats le médicament
générique serait moins
sûr moins certain moins adaptés et donc
l'un des enjeux c'était quand même de
faire en sorte que à travers l'arrivée
de médicaments génériques on puisse
dégager des marches pour l'innovation
étant entendu que l'innovation est
absolument clé et que une industrie du
médicament pour un pays donné ou pour un
continent ne peut pas se contenter de
vendre des médicaments anciens et l'une
des difficultés pour la France je crois
c'est que très longtemps nous sommes
restés un pays qui s'appuyait sur des
molécules bien identifiées donc un
marché de masse sans aller excessivement
du côté de de l'innovation si je regarde
l'évolution des PLFSS après 2017 que je
n'ai pas fait de façon très très pointue
parce que c'est un exercice
intéressant mais il faut savoir ren
oncer
je n'ai pas le sentiment que cette
maîtrise ce soit allégée donc au fond
voilà donc il me semble qu'à cette
période là nous ne sommes pas allés trop
loin pour des médicaments vieillissants
nous avons été amenés à négocier j'ai
été amené à négocier
enfin le CEPS a été amené à négocier de
manière extrêmement
comment dire serrer sur les nouvelles
molécules puisque l'arrivée du sauvel
dit est le Sophos buvy a été au fond
l'irruption de la première molécule
d'innovation de rupture il y a un avant
un après par pour les malades ça que je
veux dire c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
simplement on améliore un peu la
situation des Mayas c'est que on les
guérit ce qui n'est quand même pas tout
à fait rien
évidemment ça oblige à réfléchir à des
modèles économiques différents puisque
si on pousse la logique du médicament
jusqu'à son terme une fois que les gens
seront guéris l'auront plus besoin du du
médicament et donc on a là il est donc
normal de rémunérer cette innovation
cette innovation elle doit être
rémunérée de manière maîtrisée c'est à
dire que
et c'est toute la difficulté d'arriver à
définir ce qu'est le juste prix des
discussions s'étaient engagées à mon
époque je ne sais pas sous quelle forme
elles se sont poursuivies après avec les
représentants du lait avec les
représentants des différents industriels
pas des différentes industries mais le
LEM comme organisation et les
industriels pour savoir comment on
pouvait qu'est-ce qu'on mettait qu'elles
étaient les ingrédients si j'ose dire ou
les critères de la juste rémunération et
de l'innovation je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est nécessaire pour ma
part je crois
et c'est un point qui
renvoie la question de la publicité de
la puissance publique par rapport aux
industriels que l'enjeu de la régulation
il est majeur
moi je crois plus
pourquoi pas un pôle de production
public privé pourquoi pas au niveau
européen pourquoi pas
je ne sais pas si c'est la solution
honnêtement dire que à partir du moment
où un certain nombre de pénuries résulte
d'incidents de fabrication sur la chaîne
de production je ne vois pas pourquoi
une chaîne de production parce qu'elle
serait labellisée publique
échapperait au défaut de de enfin au
risque pas aux défauts au risque
d'incidents et donc là encore il
faudrait dupliquer en revanche tout ce
qui est constitution de stocks au niveau
européen
garantit d'approvisionnement des des
produits actifs peut-être réfléchir à la
manière dont on pourrait demander aux
façonniers de disposer de stocks de
produits actifs qui leur permettraient
de de faire face lorsque le risque vient
enfin lorsque la difficulté vient de la
rupture d'approvisionnement en produits
actif ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
tout cela me paraît nécessaire donc oui
à l'harmonisation européenne une
harmonisation européenne qui n'est pas
simplement au niveau de la fabrication
il faut évidemment aller plus loin dans
l'harmonisation réglementaire la
définition des médicaments la définition
la rapidité de mise sur le marché sans
doute une harmonisation des listes je
veux dire
ce qui la liste d'intérêt des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur on était pionniers et je me
permets de rappeler que l'inscription
elle était faite à la demande des
industriels
et les industriels ils se précipitaient
à la porte pour être inscrit sur cette
liste c'est-à-dire que la liste
apparaissait un peu comme un gage
au fond de de
reconnaissance de la qualité du
médicament donc moi je ne serai pas
choquée à l'idée enfin je trouverai
normal que après tout ça a été la
première liste
son mérite a été
fondamentalement de mettre la lumière
sur la nécessité d'apporter des réponses
pour ces médicaments là qu'on puisse
avoir
différentes listes des listes plus
restreintes ou des listes avec des
catégories différentes auxquelles
correspondrait des niveaux d'engagement
et d'implications différents moi
personnellement ça ne me choquerait pas
ce que je veux dire c'est que toute la
réflexion que j'ai eue avec mes équipes
et les différents acteurs du système
c'était sur la constitution de cette
liste qui n'allait pas de soi je veux
dire encore une fois on peut dire
aujourd'hui la liste n'est pas
satisfaisante ou la liste est trop ceci
la liste est trop cela j'observe que les
autres pays se sont engagés dans la même
voie
avec les contraintes de leurs propres
industriels de leurs propres acteurs de
leur propre culture et donc on se
retrouve effectivement aujourd'hui à
partir d'un modèle français qui a été
considéré comme pionnier j'insiste
là-dessus avec différentes listes et
donc peut-être il faut avoir des
discussions pour faire converger des
listes qui n'excluraient pas qu'il
puisse y avoir d'autres des lits
spécifiques vous voyez enfin je ne sais
pas pour trouver des modalités de prise
en charge d'accompagnement de certaines
de certains produits qui seraient
davantage consommés en France ou
d'autres mais on voit bien que
l'enjeu c'est d'avoir des listes qui à
la fois mettent l'accent sur
l'importance thérapeutique du médicament
des médicaments n'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur et puis que cela croise avec le
risque de pénurie et donc le risque
industriel ce qui n'est pas la même
chose c'est-à-dire que dans un cas vous
avez une liste qui dit voilà les
médicaments dont on ne peut pas se
passer en gros
et dans l'autre c'est les médicaments
dont on ne peut pas se passer et qui par
ailleurs sont soumis sont exposés à un
risque de
voilà et donc je pense que
c'est
cette double nature de liste ou ceux de
ce double type de liste à sa place et
peut te exister alors la licence
d'office chère madame la sénatrice c'est
un débat majeur moi je reste très
sceptique sur la licence d'office
je le dis encore une fois je n'engage en
rien mon organisation internationale
nous mais nous
unité de travail avec une ce qu'on
appellerait un organisme associé qui
s'appelle le medicine Patton pool qui
est en charge le MPP qui est bien connu
qui existe depuis nous avons créé il y a
une quinzaine d'années donc nous
finançons en 95%, et qui est un
organisme qui a la responsabilité
directe de la négociation des brevets et
nous avons vu à l'occasion du covid
effectivement que cette question des
brevets était une question centrale nous
ne travaillons pas du tout sur les pays
aux revenus nous ne travaillons pas du
tout sur l'accès dans des pays européens
nous travaillons sur la base de licence
volontaire ce qui a des limites mais qui
nous permet de poursuivre les
discussions moi l'inquiétude que j'ai
sur la licence d'office c'est que ce
soit un fusil à un coup si j'ose dire
c'est à dire que une fois que vous avez
fait une licence d'office avec un
laboratoire
puisque rien ne peut vraiment obliger où
il arrête où il trouvera d'autres
structures d'autres mécanismes ce sont
des règles internationales qui doit
faire l'objet de discussions et qui font
l'objet de discussion sur les brevets et
la propriété intellectuelle dans le
cadre de
l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce personnellement je me
permettrai d'apporter une piste
contrairement à ce que l'on dit souvent
les la recherche et développement dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique bénéficie de
fonds publics tout à fait important
qui sont d'autant plus importants que la
recherche est fondamentale quand on
regarde par exemple covid les grands
laboratoires qui ont
fait la découverte du vaccin de façon
très très spectaculaire ce sont appuyés
sur des structures plus petites soit des
startups soit des laboratoires de
recherche le vaccin
AstraZeneca n'a pas connu le même succès
que les vaccins ARN mais il s'appuyait
sur l'université d'Oxford et donc on
s'aperçoit que de façon globale et aux
États-Unis il y a des il y a eu un
engagement financier majeur on a pu dire
que l'Europe n'avait pas été assez loin
dans l'investissement au niveau de la
recherche et développement à partir du
moment où la puissance publique investit
massivement
il ne me semblerait pas anormal que dès
la négociation des contrats initiaux des
conditions sur l'accès au marché puisse
être reposés et que des conditions sur
les prix je dis les prix parce que je ne
suis pas choqué par le fait que nous
payons plus cher qu'un pays africain ou
qu'un pays
à bas revenu en Asie ou en Amérique
latine qui est une différenciation des
prix ne me paraît pas choquante ça n'est
pas parce que nous avons su négocier
l'accès au traitement hépatite C pour 70
dollars en Égypte ou les traitements
contre le sida pour moins de 100 dollars
par an en Égypte alors que c'est plus de
10000 c'est 10000 euros en Europe
voilà il y a des il y a des différences
je ne crois pas que l'idée que tout de
suite le médicament pour écouter 70
dollars partout soit une idée tenable
puisque il faut amortir des frais de
recherche et développement il faut
amortir les produits qui ne vont pas au
terme faire la recherche quand ça marche
c'est superbe quand ça ne marche pas ça
a un coup donc le prix d'un médicament
ne tient pas seulement compte du prix de
production il ne tient pas non plus
seulement compte du prix
des investissements pour ce médicament
là il doit aussi intégrer de la
recherche qui n'a pas abouti maintenant
cela ne justifie pas n'importe quel prix
et c'est ça la difficulté mais moi ma
enfin
ma suggestion qui pour le moment n'est
pas très suivi des faits mais c'est que
les pays
développés les pays qui investissent
dans la recherche et développement
profite enfin profite s'appuie sur leur
engagement et sur l'investissement
public pour négocier des conditions
d'accès et des conditions de mise à
disposition je veux dire quand même que
indépendamment de tout cela lorsqu'un
laboratoire enfin une industrie reçoit
une autorisation de mise sur le marché
en France ou ailleurs mais en France
puisque pour un produit elle a une
obligation de service public et donc il
lui appartient
de trouver des alternatives et de
garantir
l'accès de la population et des patients
à se produit alors plus rapidement deux
points quand même que vous avez
évoqué
sur le prix
il me semble qu'il y a un une piste qui
devrait être qui a commencé à être
exploré qui devrait l'être davantage que
j'avais
envisagé en 2015 dans le cadre du Plan
antibiorésistance nous avons des
médicaments de niche non pas parce qu'il
serait particulièrement innovants mais
parce qu'ils ont vocation à concerner
très peu de gens on peut pas d'un côté
dire il faut prendre moins de
médicaments
plutôt comment est-ce qu'on concilie le
fait que l'on encourage à moins prendre
d'antibiotiques et que par ailleurs il
faut qu'il y ait de la recherche pour
trouver des nouveaux antibiotiques si on
veut pouvoir lutter contre
l'antibio-résistance donc c'est vrai que
dire à un industriel on vous demande
d'investir pour des médicaments dont on
espère qu'ils ne seront jamais utilisés
c'est quelque chose qui en termes de
marché ne va pas de soi il me semble que
trouver des mécanismes de financement
spécifique soit pour maintenir des
molécules anciennes dont le la cible
est très limitée parce qu'il y a très
peu de malade soit des médicaments
nouveaux mais avec une perspective
d'utilisation assez limitée c'est
quelque chose qui ne me choque pas qui
est des mécanismes spécifiques qui
s'appliquent à ce type de
la deuxième chose
est-ce qu'il y a un défaut de
gouvernance
moi je ne sais pas si c'est ta santé
publique France de s'occuper de ça
il me semble qu'il y a une agence qui
est qui a la responsabilité de la chaîne
du médicament c'est l'agence c'est la
NSM
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
lorsque nous avons mis en place le
décret 2012 nous avons mis en place une
cellule au sein de la DGS pour son suivi
faut-il créer de nouvelles structures je
n'en suis pas certaine faut-il créer au
sein des structures existantes des
bureaux des pilotages des cellules
appeler ça comme vous voulez qui
servirait
à organiser la synergie des différents
acteurs pourquoi pas et qui est un point
focal au sein du ministère à la DGS et
qui est une structure
identifiée en charge de cela au sein de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité des
médicaments c'est peut-être une façon
d'améliorer la visibilité du pilotage
sans créer une agence nouvelle qui va se
trouver d'abord qui va prendre un temps
fou on va dire d'abord c'est un nouveau
machin j'ai entendu certains qui le
disait
qui va se heurter aux autres agences qui
vont dire notamment à la NSM qui va dire
mais vous avez besoin de cela surtout
que et je m'arrête là je crois que l'une
des pistes quand même pour travailler
sur les pénuries c'est d'améliorer la
connaissance en amont
le dispositif qui a été mis en place
c'est un dispositif
d'anticipation assez courte avec
pour pouvoir mettre en place une réponse
aussi rapide que possible aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que ce qu'il faudrait c'est
pouvoir
identifier des risques sur les chaînes
de production
six mois avant et donc il faut des
cartographies comme ça il existe toute
une série de base
en France la première la pionnière a été
celle des pharmaciens en 2013
nos j'ai oublié le nom enfin ça a été
une base
oui des ruptures il y a d'autres il y a
une base à la NSM qui a facilité les
choses il y a une base qui existe dans
d'autres domaines
peut-être que là encore la NSM pourrait
avoir la responsabilité de la
comment dire de la
synergie entre ces différentes bases de
cartographie
et là encore coopération européenne
parce que une cartographie nationale n'a
pas beaucoup de sens
et je crois je m'arrête là vraiment que
la coopération européenne est une clé
et vraiment une clé y compris si on veut
faire de la relocalisation
on pourra pas faire de relocalisation
pour tout avoir des éléments de
partage d'informations de partage de
responsabilité y compris en termes de le
relocalisation industrielle ça peut être
une bonne idée
je vous remercie beaucoup on va
compléter par les questions de
nos collègues et ajouter une ou deux
questions
madame le 11 arrivée
rapidement oui parce que l'essentiel des
questions étaient couvertes par les
questions de leur rapporteur je voudrais
revenir sur deux des petits points que
vous avez que vous avez souligné vous
avez dit à un moment
que la comparaison internationale des
prix était pas adéquate parce que il y
avait
il y avait des systèmes de rabais et
donc ça c'est mon mon interprétation il
y a donc des zones grises
donc j'aimerais que vous soyez un petit
peu plus précise là-dessus montrer
comment on peut améliorer changer ça et
vous vous expliquez sur la question des
prix qu'il faut il faut rémunérer la
recherche et que c'est normal qu'on ait
baissé les prix sur les génériques et
que finalement il faut financer la
recherche le problème c'est que vous
avez dit à un autre moment et ça nous
semble tout à fait ce qui ressort des
auditions qu'en fait on a une évolution
du modèle économique qui va de
reproduction de masse à une stratégie
une stratégie de niche et en fait on se
rend compte que ce sont plus les mêmes
acteurs qui vont faire la recherche et
le médicament innovant et la production
de masse et du coup et bien en fait
est-ce qu'il faut pas avoir quelque part
une approche différenciée
en termes de de décision publique
et puis une dernière question sur
vous dites une entreprise qui qui
obtient une AM à une obligation de
service public moi je vois pas en quoi
elle se
caractérise cette obligation de service
public et est-ce que le système de
l'autorisation précoce n'a pas permis
surenchères sur sur les prix et mis en
état de dépendance les gouvernements par
rapport à les autorités publiques par
rapport
donc Madame emiliane Pomerol
oui merci
ma question va poser aussi sur les prix
puisque bon c'est un thème qui est
récurrent
au cours de toutes ces de toutes ces
auditions
d'abord vous avez vos clés dès le début
le fait que peut être les prix bas ne
sont pas une solution et que ça alors je
voulais vous demander est-ce que ça peut
avoir le fait de si on augmentait les
prix des médicaments
matures
en françois en Europe quelles sont les
conséquences par rapport au pays pauvres
parce que il me semble que ça pourrait
avoir des conséquences or on sait
qu'aujourd'hui même dans des pays en
Europe comme la Suisse ou les prix sont
plus élevés on a quand même des
problèmes de pénurie donc le prix n'est
pas peut-être pas
le levier intéressant et moi je voudrais
avoir des précisions quand vous avez dit
avoir des critères de la juste
rémunération parce qu'effectivement nous
on a on a le sentiment qu'il y a une
opacité sur les
sans arrêt le secret des affaires et
vous avez évoqué le rôle important de la
Recherche et Développement R&D en
particulier public et on n'a jamais
de précision sur l'importance de cette
recherche et développement publique dont
la création de médicaments vous avez
évoqué le fait qu'on puisse avoir des
startups qui sont rachetés l'exemple du
gilet ou du vaccin d'ailleurs
coviders Anita c'est le rachat d'une
d'une start-up est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir vraiment des précisions sur ces
critères comment on pourrait parce que
vous dites il faut négocier dès le début
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique mais
comment on pourrait avoir des critères
qui permettent d'avoir vraiment une
négociation qui soit j'allais dire la
même sur des principes identiques en
tout cas sur tous ces nouveaux
médicaments qui sont effectivement
aujourd'hui à des prix exorbitants et
des produits de niche
nous sommes privilégiés par l'industrie
pharmaceutique ok donc je vais juste
rebondir sur cette question du prix vous
avez dit on peut baisser le prix jusqu'à
un certain point c'est quoi ce certain
point c'est quoi le point de rupture et
est-ce que finalement on doit pas plutôt
au niveau du prix du médicament garantir
une complète transparence qui
permettrait de comprendre où on met des
points de rupture et sur quelle critères
on les met en oeuvre parce que au bout
de tout ça c'est vraiment la question de
la transparence sur le prix du
médicament qui est qui se pose et qui
revient dans toutes les auditions parce
qu'un certain point quelque part
c'est pas tout à fait transparent comme
critère je vous remercie beaucoup
la question de la transparence madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrices est
une question à la fois essentielle et
difficile je crois que la transparence a
été améliorée
en tout cas c'était une de mes priorités
et un de mes objectifs de faire en sorte
que
sans toucher au principe de secret des
affaires ce qui aurait renvoyé à des
enjeux très au-delà de la Somme
industrie du médicament c'est à dire que
là on ne touche pas uniquement aux
problèmes de l'industrie du médicament
on puisse aller vers une plus grande
proximité je vais vous donner une année
je vais vous raconter une anecdote parce
que c'est aussi à travers des choses
vécues qu'on peut sentir les choses
lorsque le
Sophos vivir est arrivé
il se trouve que tous les pays n'avaient
pas le même intérêt dans ce médicament
puisque l'hépatite C n'était pas
présente dans tous les pays de la même
manière la France était un pays où
l'hépatite C était très il y avait de
très nombreux patients c'était également
le cas d'Italie c'était le cas d'autres
pays moins de
j'ai souhaité porter le débat au niveau
européen il y avait un Conseil européen
et jusque deux jours avant qui était à
Milan et jusque deux jours avant
nous espérions pouvoir j'espérais
pouvoir faire adopter une résolution qui
nous permettrait d'avancer de manière
coordonnée parce que l'idée c'était sans
pouvoir se donner le prix parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit dire que je n'avais pas
le droit de dire à ma collègue italienne
moi il me demande tant
et elle ne pouvait pas me dire je suis
en train de négocier sur temps donc on
négociait chacune dans son couloir avec
les structures nationales qui existaient
et donc
l'idée était de pouvoir
avancer grouper et d'avoir une
comment dire une position commune au
niveau européen les pays qui n'avaient
pas d'hépatite C ou peut nous disait
vous avez raison mais ne se sont pas
engagés plus que ça et puis certains
pays ont préféré jouer cavalier seul en
se disant je vais obtenir un meilleur
prix sans doute que le laboratoire leur
a dit si vous ne signez pas cette
déclaration
je vais vous faire un prix qui sera plus
avantageux le résultat est qu'il n'y a
pas eu de déclaration européenne un truc
totalement on va qui ne servait pas à
grand chose quoi donc on est arrivé très
loin je pense qu'ensuite la France a été
parmi les pays qui ont le mieux négocié
les prix et nous avons mis toute une
série de mécanismes tout ce que la
réglementation française nous permettait
des prix bas ensuite si on dépasse à
telle seuil il y avait des des des
c'était automatiquement capé au niveau
du du
PLFSS mais donc cette question de la
transparence
je pense que l'idéal serait un prix
totalement transparent je suis pas sûr
qu'on y arrive compte tenu d'un certain
nombre de mécanismes qui jouent dans
chaque pays et en réalité
chaque pays c'est la vérité et que les
laboratoires vous demande de négocier
sur un prix
accorde des rabais complémentaires dès
lors que ce qui leur permet d'afficher
internationalement des prix plus élevés
que ce qui est effectivement négocié ce
qui permet d'obtenir dans les
négociations dans d'autres pays donc le
consommateur ou le la sécurité sociale
parce que en France c'est la sécurité
sociale elle elle obtient le prix le
plus bas possible dans ce qui a été
négocié mais en termes d'affichage le
prix est plus haut parce que ça permet
au laboratoire vis-à-vis d'autres
acteurs d'aller négocier sur une base
plus plus élevée donc la question de la
transparence
elle elle est posée il m'est arrivé de
ne pas pouvoir obtenir la mise sur le
marché de produits parce que les prix
demandés étaient trop élevés sur des
niches donc voilà c'était
mais mais c'est c'est compliqué et cette
question de l'articulation entre
garantir l'accès parce que garantir
l'accès et garantir la juste
rémunération il faut trouver l'équilibre
et je ne suis pas certaine qu'on puisse
définir des critères qui soient
totalement robustes et intangible qui
vaudrait pour toutes les situations
en tout cas ne serait-ce que de poser ce
principe là c'est à dire que on ne peut
pas ne pas se préoccuper des conditions
d'accès parce que j'ai même en France
qui est un pays riche la sécurité
sociale ne peut pas assumer
voilà je veux dire moi j'ai vu sur les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale j'ai vu
l'arrivée du sauvaldi
ça se voit ça se chiffre ça se chiffre
on avait passé le milliard donc ça on le
voit et donc c'est un point qui qui est
important en revanche je crois donc
baisser les prix
des génériques enfin et des médicaments
anciens oui jusqu'à un certain point
parce qu'il y a un point où il faut de
toute façon qui est comment dire un prix
qui soit satisfaisant pour pour tout le
monde
je crois savoir ça n'était pas le cas je
crois savoir que le risque de rupture
industrielle fait désormais partie des
critères que le CEPS peut prendre en
compte donc c'est un élément plutôt
positive et encore une fois moi je crois
beaucoup à cette idée d'une approche
différenciée c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas on peut ne pas avoir la même
démarche de fixation des prix pour
l'ensemble des médicaments c'est à dire
que un médicament
qui arrive sur le marché au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années son brevet
tombe on peut le générique et il est
normal que le prix baisse il n'y a pas
de difficulté de production plusieurs
laboratoires le produit pas de
médicaments ou quand vous allez à la
pharmacie on vous propose 15 marques de
générique possible bon tout ça ne pose
pas de difficultés puis vous avez le
médicament qui ne soigne que 40000
personnes qui
n’est absolument plus rentable là il y a
des discussions à avoir lorsque ce sont
les mêmes laboratoires qui investissent
sur de l'innovation et ont des chaînes
vieillissantes il faut faire en sorte de
coupler les négociations je pense pour
faire en sorte qu'ils investissent aussi
ça c'est de l'obligation de service
public qui est un investissement sur les
chaînes vieillissantes parce que ça le
gouvernement il se retrouve l'État se
retrouve la puissance publique se
retrouve un peu démunis lorsque un
industriel dit moi je n'investis plus
donc et l'obligation de service public
pour un détenteur d'AMM c'est garantir
l'approvisionnement du marché où il a
obtenu la MM ne pas détourner ou ne pas
envoyer parce que détourner est un mot
trop fort donc je le retire à ne pas
envoyer sur d'autres marchés des
produits destinés au marché français
qui pourrait être d'autres pays
européens mais pas forcément
garantir
des stocks maintenant
garantir des alternatives thérapeutiques
réfléchir aux alternatives
thérapeutiques informés les autorités en
cas de risque sur la chaîne de
production ça ce sont des obligations de
de service public une autorisation de
mise sur le marché c'est pas simplement
un droit
vendre le médicament c'est aussi un
certain nombre d'obligations qui
s'attachent en lien avec les grossistes
répartiteurs et les pharmaciens les
grossistes répartiteurs ayant eux aussi
un certain nombre d'obligations
juste oui enfin en fait ce qui est sur
le prix du du médicament nous
effectivement le CEPS négocie ferme
j'allais dire et c'est très compliqué
d'avoir la réalité des critères qui sont
qui sont mis en dans la balance
il nous semble depuis le début de nos
auditions que évidemment il faut prendre
en compte le service médical rendu le
réel coup de production et ça c'est pas
toujours évident parce que on a la
parole de l'industriel mais bon voilà il
y a besoin de prendre en compte aussi
les critères environnementaux et sociaux
parce que plusieurs nous ont dit ce
qu'il faut pas mettre sur la boîte de
médicaments le lieu de production si les
pays appellent à relocaliser parce que
effectivement ça va un peu faire monter
le prix du médicament mais est-ce le
citoyen et citoyenne veulent mettre un
peu plus cher pour permettre que
l'industrie se rapproche d'eux donc il
faut que ça soit en tout cas des
critères environnementaux sociaux qui
soient pris en compte et la dernière
peut-être la dernière chose aussi c'est
effectivement
la juste rémunération de l'industriel
mais tout ça enfin je veux dire on
plaide je pense tout et tous pour qui
est cette transparence mais la
difficulté est y compris ce que vous
avez donné comme élément pour dire il
faut faire pression pour obtenir telle
chose telle chose
les gouvernements n'ont pas un outil
pour faire pression si c'est juste dans
un bras de fer c'est quand même assez
compliqué d'où la double l'ouverture sur
éventuellement des dispositifs publics
qui se trouvent pas du tout
remplaçant mais mais au contraire ayant
un rôle particulier il y a des
expériences intéressantes au Brésil en
Egypte même la barda aux États-Unis il y
a même en Suisse et et nous on sent
petit mauvais par rapport à ça
et juste complété parce que c'est pour
rebondir sur ce que ce qui a été dit
précédemment vous parlez d'un certain
nombre de garanties
qui dit garantit si on veut être
opérationnel on parle aussi de sanctions
quelque part et donc ce champ là reste
un champ pour l'instant
peut utiliser voir inexploré
oui sur ce dernier point madame la
Présidente la question des sanctions par
définition elle est apparue avec la mise
en place de tout un arsenal
réglementaire qui dit obligation de
constitution de stocks qui dit
obligation de plan de gestion des
pénuries qui dit respect des obligations
de mis sur le marin lié à la MM dit en
cas d'infraction
sanctions et des sanctions qui soient
identifiées qui soient
significative et qui soit
douloureuse y compris en termes d'images
publiques c'est à dire que la sanction
peut être financière souvent c'est ce
qui pèse le plus mais mais mais mais le
Naiman shame enfin le le fait de dire
qu'un laboratoire ne respecte pas des
obligations
peut-être positif même si moi je veux
croire que je veux dire que
je ne crois pas qu'il faillette dans une
approche en tout cas
même si on a parfois dit que j'étais dur
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique quand
j'étais ministre mais je ne crois pas
qu'il faillette dans une approche de
conflictualité
de principe c'est-à-dire que
accepter la perspective de sanctions ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on se place dans une
perspective ou d'emblée on considère
qu'on est en termes d'adversité je pense
que c'est un nouveau partenariat qu'il
faut arriver à établir entre la
puissance publique une et les
industriels c'est-à-dire que le le
contexte est en train de changer
dans 10 ans le monde du médicament ne
ressemblera pas à ce qu'il était il y a
10 ans parce que nous avons des
médicaments biologiques qui vont arriver
parce que des innovations de rupture
vont arriver à des coûts qui ne sont
même pas envisageables enfin il y a
personne ne pourra les payer aucun pays
riche ne pourra les payer de façon
massive alors pour les autres n'en
parlons même pas sauf ce qui veut dire
que nous avons besoin de réfléchir
collectivement à la façon de mettre en
place un dispositif de régulation mais
moi je reste convaincu que la régulation
publique est absolument nécessaire
incontournable décisive et que
la il est important pour notamment pour
les pays européens qui ont des systèmes
de protection sociale extrêmement
développées et qui garantissent des
débouchés aux industriels parce que faut
quand même faire sa solvabilise la
demande des industriels on a
ne se pose pas en Europe les questions
qu'on se pose dans les pays du Sud pour
voilà donc c'est quand même une force
extraordinaire et donc je crois que nous
avons besoin de de réfléchir à cela
alors
on ne peut pas effectivement
faire pression le mot et un mot je
voudrais distinguer deux situations en
réalité
il y a des médicaments qui sont des
médicaments de rupture à l'échelle
mondiale
type le vaccin covid donc là la
préoccupation qui est la mienne elle est
parce que les pays européens arriveront
à voir ces médicaments ils vont négocier
on l'a fait au niveau européen et moi je
pense que c'était la bonne façon de
faire que d'avoir une approche
européenne et de faire baisser les prix
et de voilà
en revanche l'enjeu il est davantage
pour les pays du Sud ce qui n'est pas la
préoccupation de votre commission et
donc c'est là où je dis
lorsqu'un médicament de rupture a fait
mondial arrive sur le marché
réfléchir enfin négocier d'emblée avec
ces industriels pour que il y ait des
vaccins des médicaments qui puissent
arriver en Afrique en Asie en Amérique
latine c'est un enjeu et qu'on ne repose
pas uniquement sur la solidarité des
pays du Nord qui vont acheter des doses
pour les donner ensuite au pays du Sud
on n'est pas dans la même démarche quand
on est dans un dans une démarche
nationale ou européenne puisque la
question de l'accès ne se pose pas
exactement dans les mêmes termes et là
il me semble
que il va falloir définir des critères
sur ce qu'est le prix de l'innovation
pour que cette innovation puisse accéder
puisse bénéficier à tout le monde et
d'autre part je pense
que la clé je me répète c'est de
probablement trouver un mécanisme de
financement adapté pour des médicaments
qui sont des médicaments vieillissants
ou à destination de population de
faibles enfin petite population je veux
dire des médicaments qui au fond sont
vieux anciens pour mais qui sont très
utiles pour
100 000 personnes 50 000 personnes ce
qui ne fait pas un marché très porteur
et donc n'incite pas à la à la à
l'investissement sur les chaînes de
production mais il faudrait avoir faire
un travail que je ne suis pas en mesure
de faire pour savoir si ceux qui
produisent ces médicaments ne produisent
pas à côté des médicaments qui eux sont
beaucoup plus rentables et donc ce qui
permettrait de faire le lien entre les
avantages qui sont apportés dans le
cadre des nouveaux médicaments qui
touchent un public plus vaste en
innovants et ont des prix plus élevés et
l'entretien de chaîne de production
vieillissante
merci beaucoup pour tous ces éléments
très précis et
voilà je le souligne pas forcément
systématiquement et la qualité de vos
réponses
je vais donc lever la séance vous
demandez si vous souhaitez apporter un
ou des éléments complémentaires
je vous remercie beaucoup en tout cas je
crois que les les questions que vous
posez sont des questions difficiles
nécessaires exigeante et je crains qu'il
n'y ait pas de réponse unique puisque
voilà on avait bien on aimerait la
mesure de ce sujet déjà en 2018 on
aimerait bien que la réponse n'était pas
unique merci beaucoup la séance levée
nous nous retrouvons chers collègues en
salle 131
à 13h30 pour l'audition du ministre
Xavier Bertrand 13h30